- So Alex Jones is defaulted, again.
It's like Groundhog Day over here.
This time in Connecticut,
where he faces additional defamation suits
that like the court case in
Texas, he has defaulted on
because of all the
shenanigans in discovery.
This time it's over some Google Analytics.
Basically, the judge
kept telling Alex Jones
and his companies to
turn over data related
to Google Analytics and
they refused to do so,
and that data definitely existed,
which the plaintiffs found out about
and brought it to the judge.
- This stunningly cavalier
attitude with respect
to their discovery obligations
is what led to the default
in the first place.
- And as a sanction, Jones
cannot argue that he did not
make a profit from the
Sandy Hook Coverage.
- Court Hereby sanctions the
defendants by precluding them
from presenting evidence or argument
that they did not profit
from the Sandy Hook coverage.
- So basically, the Connecticut cases
are going just as poorly for
Jones as the Texas case did.